this role is very physically demanding
what a physical vocabulary from your
time playing Black Widow did you bring
to this the training that you had you
know you just it's nice to be able to
come to a project like this and not feel
daunted by the physical heard of it you
know just a physical challenge but
knowing kind of what you're getting
yourself into and I've had a lot of
weapons handling experience and on a
flight training so it just helps to have
a bit of a shorthand in that department
I love you kept the sort of cyborg
robotic walk the whole time wasn't like
I was like a wedding no what was that
what that you created I imagine that
it's the major was living the very
unique experience of being a mind inside
a machine a body that there would be
this kind of space that was created
between her brain actually telling her
body to perform any function I realize
that in this space you know there was
really very little room for any extra
movement and so you know everything is
kind of like being led by her and she
she goes I think it's great that you do
play this motherly character to the
major Scarlett Johansson's character
what kind of qualities do you think or
what sort of qualities do you think the
scholar possesses this makes her so so
great at playing these sort of
gun-wielding women that are on for
badass she's very hardworking and
there's something in her that doesn't
make any compromises with the work she's
involved totally and yet she is in need
of going into the soul I feel like in
that the scene we had to do together
there was she was like breathing in all
the acting we could share together I was
lucky to work her into sci-fi films but
she has done so much more work where she
can just she's like Britta Cole
chameleon
yeah a chameleon yeah it's a very
difficult thing the word for Danish
persons are serious no what do you think
is a sort of cautionary tale about
technology as presented in this movie
well you know the question of identity
is obviously very significant in this
movie interconnectivity on the internet
making borders the less existence the
question of who we then are becomes very
very important what do you want for me
you
they did not save your life they stole
it
[Music]
you
[Music]